[Music]
it's a way the interviewer becomes an
interviewee the tables have turned
do you remember anything from our
daydream well I remember being drunk
enough that I thought I was hitting all
those notes I was almost there I feel
like it's a lot I think I could have
done it if you weren't looking right at
me
okay and I was laughing I was drunk yeah
I remember that after you left I went to
my producer and I said I feel terrible I
forgot to say goodbye to Kelly and he
said you have said goodbye to her twice
and each time you said the exact same
thing as if the first time hadn't
happened it was I think we both did that
though cuz I said that to my people I
was like I was nice I was respected I
said by right like and at my hunt my but
my husband was like just let's just go
let's just like it was
I have never I've never been drinking
the day yeah or all in my only time I've
ever drank to even now I don't drink
during the day because I'm usually
working yeah most people work during the
day it's yeah don't judge yourself too
harshly at least your husband was there
so we could see what happens what
happens with me is I've never not gotten
into a minor fight with my wife after
day drinking because she's at home with
the two kids and then I come home again
at 2:30 yeah and I like walk in all
drunk and I knock a lamp over and she'll
be like what's wrong with you and I'm
like it was for work Oh working you're
welcome you're welcome this drinking
puts clothes on our kids no one has a
problem it's fine I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this